making their own rules the cast of
stranger things and for this crew it
seems everything is right side up in the
money Department I've gotta say give it
congratulations on your raise it is
gonna be your big stranger I'm gonna buy
myself a new jacket if you'll notice I
wear one jacket to most of these events
and I think it's time that I have two
here's the strangest things pay raise by
the numbers according to reports the
kids before made 30,000 in episode
that's been bumped up to between 200 and
250 thousand Winona Ryder and David
Harbour are said to be pulling in closer
to 350 in episode and fourteen-year-old
Millie Bobby Brown well she's reportedly
cashing in close to that much as well
what's your stranger things splurge that
stuff I do not look into at all it's all
about the webcam am very excited for it
Princeton season three of strange things
going back into production next month
how are you feeling as you move into it
I just did a movie for Godzilla the
sequel and and there were no kids in
that you know so now I'm kind of going
back to work with all the kids and it's
just very exciting obviously I adore
them I'm certain to be found
you
[Music]